انسحب الاحتلال من مدينه جنين بعد تنفيذه
لمدامات واسعه في المنطقه الشرقيه من
المدينه تم خلالها اعتقال وايضا مصادره
لاموال وصيغه من احد المنازل هنا في هذا
المنزل قام الاحتلال باقتحامه بشكل همجي
كما تحدث المواطنين هنا واصحاب هذا المنزل
ومن ثم عاث فساد وتخريب واسع في ممتلكات
المنزل هنا نرصد
الخراب الذي لحق بكل مقتنيات هذا المنزل
فاتوا بطريقه همجيه يصحوا بينا طبعا احنا
صحينا طلعنا عليهم ج بقول بلش ياخذ
هوياتنا واسامينا وهيك ورقم هويات ما حكاش
شو بده يعني ولما اجوا يطلعوا بقولوا وين
معاد وبلش يسالوا نرن على معاد ومعاد
تليفونه مش معه طبعا وظل يرن وظل مصر
وبقول تع الباجر بيهدد اخوي اللي اخذوه
قوله قبل لا اخليه يفوت على الدار وانا
اخوك جيب لي اخوك وين اخوك وين مخبي هون
هون هون جيب لي اخوك وين اخوك قال له بعرف
يعني انا جاي مصحيني من النوم تسال بي عن
اخوي شو بعرفني وينه مع الحكي اخذو اثنين
وفي واحد منهم متجوز عنده
ولدين الضابط حكى مع امي اللي اجوا بيحكوا
عبري كل لهم رنوا تلفون على امي قولوا لها
انه ربي اولاده الاثنين انت هينا ناخذ
ابنك ناخذ ابنك اللي عنده اولاد واخذ
ابراهيم الثاني وال حكيتوا لنا صارت سرقه
لاموال صاروا فاتوا عند دار اخ اخوي طبعا
المصاري عند اخوي محطوطه الاخوان
العزابيه اخذوا مبلغ 40 الف والذهب يعني
اخوي بقى خاطب وفلت واخذ ذهبات و ا اه
ذهبات حمودي طبعا يعني سركوا اذا ذهب و 4
ال صحيح وكسروا المنزل صحيح ثلاث منازل
هذا ضار اخوي وفوق ار اخوي العزابي جايب
عفش حاطه بغرفه مقفلها فايتين ومطب شين كل
شيء اه مش مخليني شيء شكرا شكرا العاف اذا
يعني هذه جرائم الاحتلال المتواصله في
الضفه الغربيه اقتحامات ومداهمات يوميه
اعتقالات ومصادره لاموال وصيغه من عدد من
المنازل انسحب الاحتلال واعتقل عددا من
الفلسطينيين من المنطقه الشرقيه في مدينه
جنين ليث جعار
الجزيره